essentially you have the closed protein
shell hear that spontaneously forms from
free energy minimization processes and
this the role of this thing the role of
this protein shell for the virus is to
protect the viral cargo so the
responsibility of this thing is to
protect genome transcription enzymes etc
and hepatitis B virus which is pictured
here the leftmost yeah one is the actual
crystal crystallographic structure and
then the center the center most is via
the central one is obviously a
mathematical simplification of that
where the rhombic subunits are pictured
has little polygons and this hepatitis B
virus actually makes the functional form
is a larger t equals 4 120 p structure
which is in the center and then the
smaller one is you can even see the
dodecahedral symmetry the dodecahedral
or an icosahedron symmetry of the
smaller and all of them are actually an
Acosta cute really symmetric but these
shelves essentially protect the viral
cargo and polymerize spontaneously due
to free energy minimization and the so
the main points of the talk will be how
to come up with once you have the
conceptual the mathematical stuff down
for modeling capsule assembly kinetics
which would be a simple o de model here
differential equation model you can
model you can you know which you cannot
essentially get the information you need
for the assembly cosmetics model for
from a combination of graph theory
algorithms overlaid but with yeah the
face representation of the polygons here
and we'll go through like a toy example
of a tetrahedron assembling from
triangular subunits so if you have the
left hand side is just the rate of
change as in any differential equation
model and you have essentially cyclic
mass flow with the green arrows
representing forward mass flow towards
the target goal of in this case Z sub 4
where the subscript you just represents
the subunit size
and you essentially have a couple
biophysical parameters in addition to
standard reaction kinetics that account
for the physical scenario that we're in
where in this case you have the KF which
is the forward reaction rate the kb in
the right hand most the two right terms
of each equation you have the backwards
rate and those each have their own units
and then they have conceptual units of /
binding site so you can imagine on the
triangular subunit which is xed out
because where you can get solved for
that in terms of the other equations you
can see three edges are exposed and as
these things come together the
hydrophobic surface areas are buried on
the edges such that when you have one
comes together you have one edge buried
one one unit essentially of hydrophobic
surface area and then a third another
sub unit comes together so you
sequentially add single triangular
subunits to form Z 2 from to Z 1 Z 3
from a-z to and is e1 etc and you
essentially just propagate this on to
whatever size en z sub N and you have to
account for in the forward and backwards
reaction rates you have to account for
the difference between what is observed
in vitro and experiments so entire is
where you're trying to do light
scattering curves or something like that
with capsid assembly kinetics say with
hepatitis B virus or bovine and taro
virus something like that you have to
account for what you'll see
macroscopically which takes into account
the conceptual unit of / binding site
and accounts for the number of binding
sites that lead to and from a given
intermediate so in a situation where you
have a monomer that's the leftmost
figure with the x over it two of those
will come together and there are three
different positions on which you can
bind to give a situ from to z1 similarly
there are two binding sites that are
both equivalent for z2 to lead to this
is III etc you just add an additional
index if you have multi multiple
intermediates in a given size
configuration for a larger structure so
if you have
more equations more like say Oh
dodecahedron you're assembling that
would a bit rid of them be 12 equations
because you assume that you add
sequentially in there 12 faces to a
dodecahedron and you have to account for
the forward reaction rate
microscopically and macroscopically in
terms of what you'll see an experiment
which has to account for things like the
number of binding sites that will lead
to the next intermediate because that
will scale the reaction rate linearly
from the microscopic / binding site
reaction rate to the macroscopic
observable reaction rate so if you have
dodecahedral assembly which this model
was established just in plain text form
just by doing it all in your head all of
the comments works in your head if you
have a simplest simplest case model here
bovine and taro virus and a lot of other
viruses Pokorny virus i believe form
dodecahedral shells where the finished
product is just a set of pentagons
coming that comes together to form a
dodecahedron you can look at the
kinetics here the left is you know a
physicist version with mass fraction the
rightist concentration they're both
equivalent you start with an entire
population of monomers so just in our
previous example would be just the
triangular subunits and solution and
they gradually assemble just following
the scheme that was shown to assemble a
roughly eighty five percent caps at
under these conditions and yeah with the
parameters on the sliders here and the
bottle yeah the other biophysical
parameter that is incorporated is the
third one from it from the top on the
sliders Delta G which is just the
binding free energy how what is the
driving force bringing these things
together typically again for hepatitis B
virus that would be hydrophobic surface
area burial on the interstitial parts of
the subunit so if we go to next part I
think I can probably skip the I'm used
to talking to biologists so I give an
introduction on graph theory I think we
can probably skip that if i can find my
mouse
so yeah graph is just right it's just
nodes joined by edges and graph theory
functionality was actually added while I
was working on this problem I kind of
thought of the scheme of using graph
theory and the count of the edges to
accommodate for the stability of a given
intermediate in version 9 before a graph
theory was available and I was very
excited when grafted he was being
developed it was accessible before but
you had to circumvent some errors and
stuff like that so it was exciting that
Mathematica 10 came out shortly after
that more very laggy us graphics here
showing the property of duality which
just shows that you can represent as a
sub unit or represent a subunit excuse
me as a vertex and as such there's an
edge in the graph the overlaid graph on
the rightmost figure everywhere there's
a graphical edge everywhere that there's
a conceptual edge representing
hydrophobic surface area burial such
that the assembly process and the
intermediates are all rendered
computationally tractable because if you
want to do you know the combinatorics of
a scenario like that you can type in in
plain tex the equations for say the most
stable model which is what i showed on
the previous slide where you have just
the most like a terd intermediates of
say size three or four where instead of
you just don't even account for the
possibility of there being linear chains
of polygons you only account for the
clustered versions that you see like say
just on the top half here for size six
so essentially you just represent caps
and subunits as the vertices you
represent that the subunit contacts as
edges and this rep this renders the
entire problem computationally tractable
in a way that a computer can handle
rather than a human and the computer
thinks about the Assembly of the
octahedron on the left here in terms of
the overlaid blues cubic figure and
whereas we think of it in terms of you
know the faces coming together it's
they're both equivalent and it's kind of
unnecessary to have the face
representation but it's good
conceptually to have a figure like that
especially in talks that are very
interdisciplinary but so we will talk a
little bit about if you want to
accommodate for a say in a scenario
where you have kinetic trapping if you
add as a depreciable amount of salt that
electrostatically screens the fact that
the subunits are all identical so if
there's any charge say positive charge
on the hepatitis B virus subunit they're
going to repulse each other but if you
add salt that electrostatically screens
the positive charge reducing the extent
to which they repel and therefore
increasing the extent to which the
hydrophobic surface area causes the
subunits wants to come together you can
actually get scenarios experimentally
where you see such rapid depletion of
the subunit pool that as as
mathematically it's modeled for that
reason you can you can see experimental
scenarios where you get such rapid
depletion of the subunit pool that you
get large populations of partially
finished capsids but no no fully built
houses essentially you have a bunch of
part built houses and then you run out
of wood is essentially the idea here and
obviously if you want to account for
something that you're going to try to
see an experiment you have to eliminate
assumptions where you can and one of the
most glaring assumptions is the
assumption that if this is a stability
assorted figure then the most stable the
ones that are the least linear and the
most clustered with the most number of
edges in the underlying graph are at the
top then you want to incorporate the
other energy minimization pathways that
are possible such as the second or third
layer here which each successive one is
of comparable stability or less so as
you incorporate more energy minimization
pathways the dodecahedron happens to
have 73 different possible state
variables that can go into the model you
get more realistic and the caps at
assembly curves to get more and more
like the light-scattering curves that
you see in solution but this again
requires elimination of the assumptions
that you make for a simplest case
model which was made in something like
1994 to now where you have an algorithm
that is able to render the situation
where computationally tractable so we
can look at a more utilitarian view of
again a graph version of the assembly
pathway so this is the same figure that
I was showing it before except with each
vertex as an intermediate and each or
isomorphism if you please and each tier
as a different size so you can see of Z
sub 6 the sixth the size 6 sub size 6
isomorphisms you have something like 20
different intermediates for the
dodecahedron and of course as you scale
up in size this problem scales comet we
really which is comparable to
exponentially so as size increases it's
less and less likely that you'll be able
to exhaustively enumerate and if you
recall hepatitis B virus has 120
subunits so that's order of magnitude
larger a problem and they've been able
to demonstrate with the previous
sweeping algorithm that there's
something like 2.6 million intermediates
that can be enumerated for a size 30
structure so it's obviously kind of a
fool's hope if you don't have a strategy
essentially the you can kind of conceive
of what the effect on the mathematics
would be if you account for multiple
intermediates it just changes the four
terms so say we're considering the
equation for Z 65 the 5th intermediate
of size 6 then instead of having one
term for the polymerization to that
intermediate and the dissociation from
the larger intermediate to that
intermediate because we're just
considering association and dissociation
of one subunit here so you have up to
component for polymerization to that
intermediate you have dissociation to
that intermediate from size ZN plus one
here would be z 7i and you have negative
terms accounting for the change in the
yeah the rate of change of in here z 65
due to polymerization of z 65
z1 to form any of the Z sevens and you
have similarly dissociation of Z 65 to
the various z5 structures so it just
essentially just makes one term per
section here in too many terms that are
not going to bother scrolling over since
the mouse is being finicky but you can
just you can imagine that if there are
20 intermediates of size 6 there's going
to be a lot more mathematical terms
accounting for the interactions between
any two intermediates then there would
be if you just had one remediate per
size the means by which we actually got
this computationally was by means of a
Markov chain Monte Carlo so a memory
memory list stochastic Monte Carlo
experiments essentially where we can
just say we'll see if it lags too much
here and if it does I'll just described
it that you you can very quickly make a
do loop that constructs from the same I
think I start with vertex one each time
which happens to be that bottom face I
guess and it construct sit here it's
just reconstructing the same trajectory
but if I instead click this and tell it
to give me a new trajectory it goes
through a different trajectory and if we
freeze it anyone sighs you can save you
know size five here essentially what the
algorithm will do is you say new
intermediate you have the first one you
put it in an intermediate bank or what
you're going to construct the bottle
state space from and then you generate a
new intermediate compare it using
isomorphic graph q or a query on whether
or not the new intermediate is
isomorphic to the one in the bank or any
of the ones in the bank sequentially and
if it's not isomorphic and not
rotationally equivalent using some group
theory algorithms in Mathematica then
you can put in the bank as a new state
variable if it's not if it is isomorphic
then you can throw it out and tally the
count of that intermediate if you want
to keep track of that so this gives you
a means to generate the previous figure
that we were looking at for the 73
intermediates of size of a size 12
structure and it also gives you a means
to bias the assembly process so in the
du Loup essentially here where you add a
single subunit per time you can bias it
towards stability such that if there's
one node that's going to add three edges
upon incorporation rather than a node
that's going to add only one you bias it
with some arbitrary bias to
preferentially generate most stable
intermediates such that for a larger
problem where you can't possibly
exhaustively enumerate a size 120
structure and all the comments really
possible intermediates you can
preferentially generate most stable
intermediates to then use in the model
instead because it has been demonstrated
as I'll show that that is a reasonable
approximation to the kinetics of the
exhaustive system will skip we'll skip
the rules here I kind of mentioned them
it's just group theory plus the
isomorphism query the see how we're
doing on time here so if you incorporate
73 state variables rather than just the
12 you can see that it's very similar
trajectory except there's actually a
little bit larger a capsid population at
early time frames and it come commence
compensatory a lower fraction of caps
and in the late curve before it reaches
a similar equilibrium value and I have
comparing figures in the next slide here
and for fitting a system it's important
that the curve fit you know the entire
portion of the curve you don't only want
the model to equilibrate to the proper
value you want it to have the right form
so that you know you're getting the
dynamics right at least to what extent
you have experimental evidence for a
curve so essentially early trajectories
are corrected by the incorporation of
multiple intermediates of per size
because you are more adequately
representing the energy minimization
pathways during the assembly process
we'll go to the next slide here really
quickly it so in order to demonstrate
and this probably the last thing I
talked about here in order to
demonstrate that this is a feasible
thing to do think that this could scale
up to size 120 rather than just size 12
as i've been using here
you can see that if you only incorporate
the size 12 intermediates here which is
the dashed line for this middle figure
is just the top 12 for the dashed line
and then the colored line is the 73
equation exhaustive system you can see
that you get most of the kinetics from
the most stable intermediate model that
was made about 20 years ago except when
you enumerate them when you ignore eight
the other oh god what is it 16 or 60
state variables you get very subtle
change but you get very diminishing
returns as you incorporate less stable
intermediate so this this figure over
here the dashed line instead of the
colored line still represents the
exhaustive model the dashed line if you
can see it here represents a 27 equation
system which is the top three tiers here
so instead of just the top layer of the
most stable intermediate model you have
a truncated enumerated system where you
have 27 or the top three tiers here and
you can see that it's almost the same
kinetic system and exactly you have very
little bit very little change but the
amount of system change per state
variable added is rapidly diminishing /
yeah as you go deeper into of the
assembly funnel it's been called so
essentially it that demonstrates that
for larger structures and we've tested
it we've tested out in my boss and his
collaborators have tested out for larger
structures with a different algorithm
that was not really tractable to someone
other than the author really they've
tested it for size 20 and size 30
intermediates and seen similar results
that you can scale this thing such that
even though you can't enumerate or you
can't integrate all 2.6 million possible
comet oriole combinations of
intermediates of size 30 you can still
get say like a rhombic tetrahedra try a
conta Heatran I think even though you
can't integrate that you can integrate a
large enough fracture that you see very
rapid diminishing returns in terms of
the integration of the system and the
state any other change in the end caps
at curve
the main goal of a project like this
would be to do curve fitting of light
scattering curves for example because
light scatters things proportional to
the radius of the thing doing this
scattering so essentially if you have a
large caps at a large ligament that is
in solution and you shine a light of a
certain frequency on it the light will
be scattered proportional to the radius
of the thing that's doing the scattering
and you can get you can construct from
this concentration curves and
essentially analyze the concentration
dynamics of the system and yeah this was
made possible with you mathematica and
the enumeration algorithm that I've
shown with the graph theory and I think
that's probably we're probably running
low on time okay yeah so that'll
probably be the last thing that I talked
about but yeah what my boss came up with
most of the mathematics and we're going
to try to adjust the mathematics but at
this point most of it has been a
computational problem that we're finally
able to address with graph and graph 3d
functionality that's been added in
Mathematica so that is exciting and I
think that'll be the last thing we
talked about we'll skip the biology
stuff